♪ ♪
>> Laura: WITH US NOW, BOB
WOODSON CIVIL RIGHTS ICON AND
SICK AND TIRED OF THE CRITICAL
RACE THEORY POISONING OUR
SCHOOLS AND PUBLIC DISCOURSE.
776 UNITES INITIATIVE FIGHTING
BACK.
IN A NEW BOOK, RED, WHITE, AND
BLACK, RESCUING FROM RACE
HUSTLERS, IT COMES AS THE HOUSE
DEMOCRATS LOOK TO RUN
THROUGH A RADICAL REPARATIONS
BILL.
BOB WOODSON JOINS ME NOW.
CONGRATS ON THE BOOK.
I HAVE TO ASK YOU, WHY IS THE
LEFT SO ADAMANT, AND YOUR MIND,
WHAT IS THEIR GOAL ABOUT
SATURATING OUR SCHOOLS WITH THIS
RACE OBSESSION?
>> THEY REALLY DON'T CARE ABOUT
BLACK PEOPLE, THEY REALLY ARE
DOING THIS USING THE BLACK
EXPERIENCE AND OUR BIRTH DEFECTS
OF RACE TO UNDERMINE THE
UNDERMINE THE FUNDAMENTAL
INSTITUTIONS OF OUR SOCIETY.
AND THEY ARE DOING THIS BY
PROMOTING THE FALSE NARRATIVE.
1619 IS A FALSE NARRATIVE THAT
PAINTS AMERICA AS A TALK CHRISSY
AND THEREFORE ALL WHITES ARE
DOWN NOT BENEFIT FROM WHITE
SUPREMACY AND THEREFORE THEY
MUST PAY REPARATIONS AND ALL
BLACK PEOPLE ARE VICTIMS TO BE
PITIED AND PAMPERED.
AND IF SO WHAT WE DID, SINCE
THEY WERE USING THE ISSUE OF
CIVIL RIGHTS AND JUSTICE, WE
ORGANIZED 28 OUTSTANDING
SCHOLARS AND ACTIVISTS TO OFFER
A COUNTER NARRATIVE TO THE LIES
AND FALSEHOODS THAT ARE BEING
PERPETRATED ON THIS PUBLICATION.
WE GIVE AN INSPIRATION, AN
ASPIRATIONAL CHALLENGE TO THEIR
ASSUMPTION.
ONE OF THOSE ASSUMPTIONS IS THAT
THE ONE CORRIDOR OF BLACKS WHO
ARE LIVING AND DRUG-INFESTED
CRIME NEIGHBORHOODS THAT THIS IS
THE LEGACY OF SLAVERY AND
JIM CROW.
WE TALK ABOUT HOW BLACKS PROSPER
IN THE PRESENCE OF JIM CROW.
WE BUILT RAILROADS, WE BUILT
HOMES, WE BUILD BUSINESSES,
HOTELS, MEDICAL SCHOOLS, 100
COLLEGES.
OUR ESSAYS HAVE PRODUCED
CURRICULUM THAT WE HAVE RELEASED
TEN OF THOSE LESSONS THUS FAR.
THERE HAVE BEEN 11,000 DOWNLOADS
ON THE PART OF EDUCATORS AND
OTHERS SEEKING ACCURATE AND
COMPLETE ACCOUNTING OF AMERICAN
HISTORY.
WE ARE EXCITED, WE ARE
CHALLENGING THIS NARRATIVE.
BUT WHAT THEY ARE DOING, LAURA,
IS REALLY DEMEANING TO BLACK
AMERICA TO ASSUME THAT WHATEVER
CHANGE OR REFORM THAT COMES MOST
COME FROM WHITE AMERICA.
>> Laura: AND THEIR REPORTS
TONIGHT OUT OF CHICAGO, BOB,
THAT MAYOR LORI LIGHTFOOT, I
KNOW YOU TWO ARE PILES, IS ONLY
NOW GRANTING IN ONE-ON-ONE
INTERVIEWS TO BLACK OR BROWN
JOURNALISTS.
>> AGAIN --
I'M SORRY.
>> Laura: IS THIS WHAT RACIAL
PROGRESS LOOKS LIKE?
>> YOU KNOW, THEY ARE USING
RACISM TO CONQUER RACISM.
I MEAN, AS WE SAID, WE FOUGHT TO
GET PIGS AWAY FROM THE TOWER.
AND WHAT THEY ARE DOING IS SO
INSULTING AND DEMEANING TO BLACK
AMERICA.
THE ASSUMPTION IS THAT UNLESS
AND UNTIL WHITE PEOPLE CHANGE
AND REFORM, THERE'S LITTLE WE
CAN DO AS IF WE HAVE NO AGENCY,
AS IF WE HAVE N